look you've had a good career
I don't think you're a big bad Master
spy
I think you just
messed up
I think you might have been angry about
what's going on the Russians attacked
our democracy
campaign reality
were you surprised to see us today
is my partner what partner Wally Taylor
hey how are you
we have a search warrant for your house
oh my goodness okay
would you like to see it yes please
125 pounds you guys flatter me
[Music]
I have a sense of humor I was on your
driver's license that's right
okay well I lied don't we all
reality
what if I said that you printed out
classified information
that document was made its way outside
of NSA
and the most likely candidate
is you
I think you know a lot more than what
you're telling us at this point
I'm trying to deploy I'm not trying to
be a whistleblower that's crazy
now why I'm here is to figure out the
why behind this look over here
reality
was there something that just
pushed you over the edge on this